Salut
avant de commencer cette nouvelle true story...
Oui, je dis "trou story", c'est la marque de fabrique
de ces trues stories !
Je vais vous parler de ce que j'ai mis en place cette semaine.
J'ai fait un test sur la vidéo de lundi
et sur la vidéo d'hier.
J'ai commencé la vidéo en disant :
"Derrière ce titre putaclic se cache..." etc, etc.
C'était un vrai test pour voir les réactions,
parce que, oui, j'ai du mal avec le mot "'putaclic"
Je l'ai fait seulement 2 fois,
et hier, j'ai eu énormément de commentaires, je vous invite à regarder les commentaires d'hier,
disant que c'était agaçant que je dise que c'était un titre putaclic
parce que c'est pas un titre putaclic,
et ça devient saoûlant que je fasse ça.
2 fois seulement !!!
Et je suis d'accord que c'est agaçant d'entendre ce mot tout le temps, pour tout et n'importe quoi.
Mais moi, comme je lis tous vos commentaires, je le lis tout le temps, pour tout et n'importe quoi
Ce qui pourrait même me faire passer l'envie de lire les commentaires, des fois, je vous avoue
il m'en faut plus,
Mais ça ne te met pas dans une bonne énergie.
Et puis il y a eu l'inverse : il y a un commentaire, d'hier
qui explique que oui, c'est embêtant que je fasse des
titres putaclic comme le titre d'hier,
qui est un titre putaclic.
Et la vidéo traite du fait
de mettre son mental à 0, donc de le
mettre K.O. par extension
et parle de méditation donc le mot
méditation c'est tout le thème de la vidéo.
Bref, je ne reviendrai plus jamais là-dessus, j'ai fait mon test, j'ai vu ce qui en ressortait
et pour moi, ma conclusion c'est que ce mot, aujourd'hui
n'est plus du tout maîtrisé, et ceux qui l'utilisent à tort et à travers
se rendent pas compte à
quel point ça peut être agaçant en fait
quand on lit les commentaires et que ça
peut un peu passer l'envie
moi, ça me la passe pas mais je comprends qu'il y ait d'autres youtubeurs qu'aient arrêté
en fait avec ça.
Eh c'est pas une leçon que je suis en train de faire
j'avais juste envie de partager un sentiment en fait.
Mais aujourd'hui c'est une journée true story alors
alors générique !
(Musique du générique)
L'histoire que je vais vous raconter est vraiment arrivée et depuis le temps que je la raconte à mes amis
Ils m'ont dit d'en faire une vidéo.
Alors quand j'étais un petit peu plus jeune j'ai fait des tests chez l'ophtalmo, régulièrement et
il y avait ma marraine aussi avec qui j'étais parti en vacances
qui avait demandé à ma mère
de s'inquiéter un peu de mes yeux parce qu'elle trouvait que je lisais mal les panneaux
Je crois que ça en était resté là à l'époque,
et que j'avais dit non je lis très bien.
Et moi je savais que j'avais un problème pour lire parfois
Enfin c'était un petit peu compliqué en fait
Depuis toujours je sens bien que je vois pas de loin avec cet œil là
et que je vois pas trop de près avec cet œil là.
Mais j'avais un petit peu noyé le poisson.
Et puis vers l'adolescence, il y avait un système qui existait où avant tes 16 ans,
tu pouvais aller consulter un ophtalmo gratuitement,
un espèce de dépistage des yeux j'en sais rien.
D'ailleurs je sais pas vraiment si c'était un ophtalmo
ou un médecin un peu tu sais comme la médecine du travail
un truc un petit plus généraliste, je me souviens plus très très bien de ça,
tout ce que je me souviens c'est qu'il m'a fait le test d'acuité visuelle
c'est le test de Monoyer pour voir si on voit bien de loin,
et de loin, moi, ça va pas très très bien, je le sais depuis toujours,
il faut savoir que je voulais pas porter de lunettes
j'ai jamais voulu de lunettes, j'veux pas porter de lunettes,
donc quand on est arrivés là-bas, on était face au bureau,
j'ai bien pris le temps de mémoriser toutes les premières lignes du test de Monoyer
simplement en utilisant les moyens mémotechniques que j'avais déjà à ma disposition
genre je sais que ça commence par M R T parce que j'avais le mot "morte" dans ma tête..
C'est pas très gai tout ça.
.. "va faire une écharpe" pour V F U E
etc, etc, sur les 6 premières lignes parce que, vraiment,
de loin, c'est un peu compliqué.
Mais il y a quelque chose que j'arrivais à distinguer, c'est la forme, la tâche
donc je savais si le médecin me faisait voir le 4e ou 5e et je prenais le temps de répondre
et puis j'ai bien pris soin aussi d'insérer quelques petites erreurs pour être crédible
et donc j'ai eu 9 et 10 ou 8 et 9 je me souviens plus de ça
enfin j'ai eu 2 très bons résultats à mes yeux
et j'ai pas eu de lunettes
et le temps passe (x3)
j'ai eu de la médecine du travail, j'ai fait la même chose
et ce qui est génial c'est que le test de Monoyer il ne change pas
j'vous dis pas de faire pareil, hein, parce que au final en fait y'a un problème qui ne se règle pas
mais c'était assez rigolo de se dire bah il change pas en fait
donc les gens peuvent tricher
mais en fait à cette époque là j'avais pas compris que ça servait à rien de tricher
pour sa santé en fait c'est complètement stupide.
Mais bon, j'ai pas dit que j'étais toujours un grand malin.
Et là plus ça va quand même, plus ça pose problème
c'est à dire quand je regarde, quand je vais voir des spectacles
je suis souvent au fond de la salle
je vois comme si... comme si j'avais de... de l'eau ou des larmes dans les yeux je vois trouble
alors si je fais ça
je ne vois que dalle au loin
mais si je fais ça je ne vois que dalle de près
donc en fait il y en a toujours 1 des 2 qui compense
Et je suis donc, enfin, allé chez l'ophtalmo il y a quelques jours
donc j'ai fait les vrais tests
de toute manière là il y a plus possibilités de tricher parce que tout est automatique
ça envoie des trucs sur rétro projecteur à distance donc tu peux pas anticiper en fait ce qu'il y a
donc les résultats sont, donc, que je suis
Hypermétrope de l’œil droit
myope de l’œil gauche
et astigmate des 2 yeux, c'est à dire que des 2 yeux j'ai du mal avec les lignes, les contours,
ce genre de choses et ça, ça me fatigue beaucoup le cerveau en fait
pour analyser et rectifier tout ça en permanence
Donc ça y est je vais aller me faire faire des lunettes
C'est ça en fait le résultat, ce que je ne voulais pas je vais aller le faire. Alors bon
après je les mettrai bien quand je voudrais
en fait c'est surtout aussi quand je monte etc... que je me fatigue les yeux ou quand je vais voir un spectacle
[ton dépité] mais je vais avoir des lunettes quoi
je suis dégoûté en fait
En plus, je trouve ça classe les lunettes, il y a pleins de personnes que je connais qui ont des lunettes
et c'est plutôt stylé tu vois mais
moi je sais pas pourquoi ça passe pas
[Riant] j'ai pas envie d'avoir de lunettes
mais bon, hypermétrope, myope et astigmate. C'est à dire que bientôt la chaîne elle va s'appeler ...
Daredevil Mentalisme
Voilà ça me faisait rire de vous raconter cette True Story,
parce que ça me permet de révéler ce petit côté, un petit peu escroc
d'avoir, toute sa vie, appris tout le test en entier via un moyen mnémotechnique
pour pouvoir à chaque fois faire "Ah ben non j'ai de super bons yeux moi tout va bien"
et au final ça aura servi à rien puisque maintenant je vais faire les lunettes
Enfin si, il y a un truc quand même rigolo c'est que l'ophtalmo que je suis allé voir il m'a dit:
"En tout cas c'est pas une dégénérescence, c'est quelque chose que vous avez toujours eu, c'est pas l’œil qui a fatigué avec le temps
donc vous avez toujours été comme ça. C'est assez drôle qu'il a fallu attendre plus de 30 ans pour vous en rendre compte"
Tu m'étonnes
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de mettre des... pleins de pouce en l'air
en fait
On a une règle qu'on va réinstaurer
c'est tout les 10 000 pouces en l'air que je refais une true story
comme ça, ça évite d'en avoir trop souvent.
C'est quand même pas le concept de la chaîne
mais comme ça aussi quand c'est beaucoup demandé j'en refais une autre
Demain vous aurez une vidéo un petit peu surprenante que j'ai fait...
grâce à quelqu'un qui fabrique des énigmes
en fait je viens de vous donner le thème de la vidéo de demain *rire*
Allez portez vous bien, passez un bon week end
Le Mental Vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Du 1er janvier au 31 décembre. On est déjà au mois de décembre c'est juste ouf ça
Rendez vous demain à 17h.
Non à 11h on sera samedi
On s'en sort quand même
Ciao !